mimi dimanche soir sur le réseau social
Tik Tok une femme se connecte en direct
dans la région où le petit Emine a
disparu devant plusieurs centaines de
personnes connectées elle explore les
alentours guidées par ses intuitions et
les prétendues dont des internautes
mais je vous raconte pas comment t'es
pas loin t'es pas loin vous pouvez pas
être plus précis que ça en tant que
japonais
[Musique]
je vous ai fait parler justement des
moments elle fait comment la grenouille
chérie
[Musique]
mais tout petit
peu
on aurait dû garder le silence j'aurais
pas raté
je suis désolé ça faisait combien
d'heures que vous étiez là
une heure et il fait froid mais c'est
pas grave je vais attendre le prochain
train il est possible que votre tête
soit mise à prix dans ce cas et bien
vous recevrez un Email pour vous
prévenir c'est celui de l'ange de la
mort un escroc qui se fait passer pour
un tueur à gage déjà il se présente je
suis le des Angel en anglais ça fait un
peu plus de leshouldiens j'effectue
toutes sortes de services liés au crime
organisé y compris l'enlèvement voir le
meurtre pour justifier son travail et
surtout pour que ça parle à tout le
monde il vous donne les mobiles
possibles qui peuvent expliquer qu'on
veuille vous tuer
il va se moquer de moi je pense que à
ses yeux je suis ridicule
[Musique]
bonjour
konichiwa bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
de l'amour concurrence sur le lieu de
travail personne trompée jalousie tout
simplement au moins le panel est large
chacun aura sa raison de faire appel au
des anges ensuite il précise qu'il
dispose d'informations vous concernant
vos itinéraires vos horaires de
déplacement vos habitudes il évoque
aussi les moyens dont ils disposent pour
arriver à ses fins le poison l'azote et
vous l'avez vu venir pour mettre fin au
contrat il vous demande de le payer sous
48 heures
je suis bloqué ça vient pas
petit bonus non négligeable si vous
coopérer il vous donne le nom de la
personne qui veut votre mort et si vous
aviez la mauvaise idée d'en parler à la
police l'Ange de la Mort voit tout c'est
tout il vous surveille le ministère de
l'Intérieur invite toute personne ayant
reçu ce mail à le signaler l'extorsion
est un délit possible de sept ans
d'emprisonnement et de 100.000 euros
d'amende
c'est pas légal quoi
ok ok 16 ans de commune et là ça va le
trombone de Michael lui il est en train
d'enregistrer pour une autre pour une
station de radio il fait des jingles
pendant ce temps là il fait ok comme ça
au moins j'aurais comme bouffer mon
vieux jours cette façade gay
accueillante celle d'un immeuble
abritant d'un important service public
l'Agence nationale
pour accueillir ce qu'on appelait encore
les travailleurs voilà Monsieur le
prochain pointage le 19 à la même heure
sur ces images la NPE est une nouvelle
administration et c'est un tout jeune
secrétaire d'État Jacques Chirac qui l'a
créé en 1967 c'est pour ça qu'on vous
dites que je suis momie je suis pas du
tout une momie j'ai pas dit non mais bon
c'est sûr que la mise en place c'est pas
faite ça ça m'énerve non mais ça a l'air
un peu un peu d'être en retrait un peu
je suis pas molle
il faut qu'elle fait elle a besoin de
crier
c'est
normal qu'elle crie
je crois qu'elle a aimé
et si vous êtes là c'est parce que vous
avez un projet c'est d'aller jusqu'à
jusqu'à New York
ah non ça c'est Janine excusez-moi
excusez-moi vous êtes Sylvie c'est bien
ça c'est notre fiche je voyais Sylvie
qui me regardait avec un air non je veux
pas y aller à New York non ça c'est
génial tout va bien j'ai
[Musique]
oui c'est le moment
dréage juste
qu'on le précise bien avant disant je ne
veux pas donner mon corps justement à la
science ou une partie de mon corps à la
science ce que j'ai demandé à j'ai
demandé à Fabien de faire cette lettre
formellement pour que ça parce que je
suis suisse aucun ah c'est vrai que tu
es Suisse toi pour les impôts
c'est pas avec ce que tu me payes que je
vais en avoir beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je me suis pacsé avec
l'homme de ma vie devant la mairie
Cabrel l'une des plus belles chansons
d'amour du répertoire français pour moi
je l'aime à mourir bon j'ai quand même
essayer de mettre un peu de sérieux
là-dedans en contactant la direction
générale des finances publiques pour
essayer de savoir pourquoi ils avaient
décidé de pousser la chansonnette ils
m'ont répondu en m'expliquant que
c'était une façon de parler aux jeunes
j'estime que l'homme doit être supérieur
à la femme
à tout point de vue d'ailleurs pour le
ménage pour les décisions pour pour
beaucoup de choses pour les enfants je
trouve que l'homme est supérieur et je
trouve que il doit dominer la femme
est-ce que vous souffrez d'être sous la
dépendance de votre mari non pas du tout
pas du tout
allez lui faire un petit bisou magique
voilà regardez
on se fait un petit bisou
c'est pas celle-là c'est celle d'à côté
si vous voulez embrasser Sylvie allez-y
aussi
allez tomber pas surtout
c'est important au Japon de manger en
faisant du bruit et pourquoi faut faire
du bruit retour parce que c'est bien
meilleur
ah c'est meilleur quand on fait du bruit
je suis désolé
merci